hi I'm Erik Bosse and Benham has a new
trailer that finally shows us the slimy
hokey and Spidey villain or an antihero
and gives us a new way to say the word
sin do we call them symbiotic human
symbiotic oh that's gonna be fun to hear
over and over again let's break down
this trailer for all the details that
you missed and spoiler warning in case
any of these predictions end up being
right let's get started thank you for
bringing us collectively to this moment
it is a moment it's so many of dreamed
of claiming history starts today
this trailer opens with the shots of a
crash site with the cleanup crew
investigating this crash spacecraft from
which they harvest this symbiote in the
Marvel Comics the Venom symbiote is
indeed an extraterrestrial life-form a
race that calls itself the Clint are the
symbiote attaches itself to spider-man
on his way back from space turning him
into a dark impulsive version of himself
and giving him this cool black suit
until oh Peter Parker detaches it and it
reattached as to his rival at the Daily
Bugle Eddie Brock this movie appears to
keep the symbiotes otherworldly origin
while bypassing the spider-man step
which does bring up some interesting
questions and I'll get to later over all
this we hear the voice of Carlton Drake
played by Riz Ahmed he's the head of the
Life Foundation this movie's shadowy
scientific research company that
experiments on humans because he always
gotta have one of those this movie's
stories inspired partly by the venom
lethal protector comic which features
the life foundation as a survivalist
cults who plan to rebuild society after
a nuclear holocaust they experimented
with new forms of the symbiote to create
five soldiers for themselves scream
agony riot phage and Lasher in the
storyline venom turns from villain to
sort of hero teaming up with spider-man
to take these guys down but the big
thing to point out in this part of the
trailer is that we now see at least two
different symbiotes in the back of
drake's truck notice that they appear to
have slightly different color tones
maybe it's the light in here but one of
them looks slightly bluer in the one of
the back has a black-ish grayish color
it's possible that the black one could
be used to make the main Venom symbiote
that's attached to Eddie Brock and the
others with different colors we'll
create one of the other symbiote forms
like maybe riot let me know what you
think but let's move on
the guy who is the evil person I don't
want for him my phone works better are
you gonna behave yourself tomorrow I
totally don't want to my job I'm a
reporter I follow people that do not
want to be followed what about the
allegations that you recruit the most
vulnerable for tests that end up killing
people is that a threat okay in this
section we get a sense of what kind of
reporter Eddie Brock is real life
reporters tend to be like pushy nerds
but not Tom Hardy
he drives a motorcycle and he gets big
interviews with closed off evil
industrialists that he just blows up
with gotcha questions I'm Eddie Brock
and I report the truth for vice and I
don't give up we see him dining with
Michele Williams his character and
weighing in the comics Anna's is a
strange wife but here they appear to
still be together
and we learned that Ann's law firm
represents the light foundation the
company Eddy's investigating which in
the real world would be a pretty serious
conflict of interest in a breach of
journalistic ethics but Eddie Brock is
too cool to care about that [ __ ] joking
aside I really like Tom Hardy's Cavalier
take on Eddie Brock the character needs
to have attitude because it's that
attitude that the symbiote feeds on to
create the venom persona let's move on
you had to learn how to hide in plain
sight I'm pretty good at it
you suck whoever you are I work at the
Life Foundation and I need your help we
found something we call them symbiosis
Carleton Drake believes that the union
between human and symbiote is the key to
our evolution okay here we meet Jenny
slates character she works for the light
foundation we saw her standing behind
Carleton Drake in that truck shot
earlier rumor has it that her
character's name is Doris skirt she
appears to be some kind of whistleblower
seeking out Eddie to leak some of the
evil deeds at the light foundation has
gotten into notice how the new symbiote
we see in this shot has yellowish
streaks on it Carlton has enclosed a
person in there with it and if that
colour Theory ends up being correct that
could make this figure scream or phage
scream is the woman Donna Diego in phage
is a man Carl Mac could be a woman with
the long hair there it's a little hard
to tell and yeah let's talk about slates
pronunciation of symbiotes as sim biota
symbiosis in backyard yes it does sound
weird and according to merriam-webster
this trailer caused lookups four
symbiotes to skyrocket but they said
despite symbiotes being the more common
way to say it sin biota is also an
acceptable pronunciation so for anyone
who has a problem with it being bi it's
actually okay for it to go both ways and
real quick we see another test subjects
trapped in in the lab this could be
another one of the five symbiote spawns
perhaps Raymond Hernandez who becomes
Lasher but notice how the monitors that
the shot cuts to actually reads subject
brach so this is from a different scene
I'm guessing those shots of Eddie Brock
in the MRI screaming that's a symbiote
takes over by the way I'm not sure
that's an MRI exactly because those
monitors are measuring decibels and
sonic frequencies which are known to
aggravate the symbiote that's how Peter
Parker scared it off but MRIs use radio
waves in the electromagnetic energy not
Sonic waste no there's a lot of nerd
stuff there so let's move on to the next
section
I'm feeling really sick
I'm hearing voice
in this section Eddie investigates the
light foundation labs after hours seeing
this one female test subject this could
be Donna Diego scream or Leslie Goodson
area the symbiotes agony notice how her
enclosure appears to have frost on the
floor with ice on the services it's not
clear if this is being caused by lower
temperatures in the lab or a side effect
coming from the woman herself whoever
she is she escapes and jumps on Brock
this could be a brockett's infected with
the symbiote notice how as he runs out
of the lab he's holding his head in his
neck with his hand almost as if he was
bitten there or maybe that symbiote got
into his ear we see the symbiote begin
to infect Eddie's body causing this
creepy inky effect on his pupils and
then one of my favorite elements of this
trailer the voice of venom I am loving
the vocal effect and sound editing
giving venom this deep demonic rasp
many of you were wondering who is doing
Venom's voice but from what I can tell
it's possible this is just Tom Hardy
himself with a few audio effects either
way the contrast between Tom Hardy's
voice for Eddie Brock and the voice we
hear from the symbiote in his mind is
giving this movie a really cool Jekyll
and Hyde element that really cuts to the
core of what makes venom such a cool
character let's move on you're not real
you were just in my head I'm gonna need
mr. Drake's property back
[Music]
why would we do okay in this clip Eddie
takes out a bunch of grunts from the
life foundation coming to reclaim what
he stole
so I'm guessing whatever Eddie got
infected with was the full symbiote
sample that Drake no longer has has
supposed to do some kind of infection
from one of the already exposed test
subjects the leader of these grunts is
rolling Treece played by Scott Hayes
it's interesting to see Venom's power is
in action here the symbiote forms into
these tendrils that protrude out of
Eddie's limbs and back to attack these
guys now it's a little tricky because
traditionally venom takes a sticky web
form because it's mimicking spider-man
it was attached to Peter Parker before
Eddie Brock and it remembers those
spider er abilities so here wouldn't
totally make sense for Eddie Brock's
symbiote to sling inky webs around the
as spider-man hasn't been in the picture
now he might make a cameo in this movie
but he won't be a major part of Venom's
origin here but I guess it doesn't
matter because really the star of this
is Tom Hardy's acting his reaction to
all this seems very natural and
naturally confused
his delivery on why would we do that
shows how his identity is cracking into
two parts and one last thing if you were
me you probably miss the big kitchen
knives hanging on the wall right by the
door now I know this is like a studio
apartment but it's not the safest place
to set knives this movie is aiming for
an R rating so uh it wouldn't surprise
me at all to see those knives get used
in the fight some very graphic way let's
move on
if you're gonna stay you will only hurt
bad people do we have a deal okay here
are some shots of this great street
chase with Eddie trying to outrun these
projectile drone missiles also Eddie
struggles for control against the
symbiote president you will only hurt
bad people remember venom is the hero of
this movie so it can't be all bad
unfortunately this shot of him looking
in the car window before getting slammed
back against a brick wall makes me think
we might see him talking to Venom's
presence in the reflection of the glass
maybe actually we'll get some little
nods to Norman Osborn talking to his
evil reflection in the first spider-man
film I could watch Willem Dafoe talk to
himself in a mirror all day long let's
move on to the next clue
willing to sacrifice
thing you hold most dear
in this section we see some more cool
shots of this chase sequence these
tendrils grab the steering wheel of the
SUV pursuing him and then blows back
both vehicles we also see Eddie taking a
jog through the woods and then smashing
through this fallen tree suggesting that
the symbiote is enhancing Eddie's own
strength
even when venom hasn't taken over
there's also this shot of Anne looking
up and concerned now check out the
furniture of this room this is the same
location as that overhead shot were a
ton of office employees the desktops are
being swept away now my last trailer
breakdown I got into some theories on
what could be causing this since this
kind of telekinesis isn't really one of
Venom's powers but apparently the target
of this attack is and chew on that as we
move on to the final section you should
be what the hell are you
[Music]
I'll fit
after a quick shot at symbiotes
spreading across eddies face there's
this quick shot of Eddie Rhee
confronting Carlton Drake telling him
you should be extremely afraid to me
this sounds like less of a threat as it
does a genuine warning it's almost like
Drake has captured Eddie and plans to go
further with his experimentation and
Eddie's saying trust me you should be
very afraid of this thing now one thing
that's been missing from these trailers
is the villain that was announced last
year carnage it was rumored that Woody
Harrelson we were playing the role in
the comics carnage was created when
Eddie Brock shared a prison cell with
the serial killer Cletus Kasady Eddie's
symbiote produced an offspring that
bonded with Cassidy turning into the far
more violent and sadistic carnage my
guess is that if carnage does indeed
come into this story he'll be revealed
in a later trailer perhaps something
this summer like a comic-con and maybe
creating carnage is what Carlton Drake
is trying to do here in this scene the
petty and then after a quick shot of
Eddie getting some serious air on his
motorcycle and his symbiote in drools
reattaching him to it we get the real
money shot of this trailer this is I
love the way Venom's toothy mouth closes
over Eddie's head as if it's literally
swallowing him reflecting the way venom
swallows and his identity to take over
along with Eddie's voice transforming
from his normal tone to the deeper more
animalistic tone
[Music]
several rows of teeth the long drooly
tongue in the slimy texture all
perfectly adapted from the characters
classic design but one big question here
is what emblem if any appears on Venom's
chest it's hard to tell from the wide
full-body shot if there's anything there
in the comics Venom's emblem is a white
spider a bizarro version of spider-man's
emblems since his identity was a
mirrored version of spider-man's
identity but again since spider-man
probably isn't gonna be part of Venom's
origin here it wouldn't really make
sense for his emblem to be anything
spider related but notice those white
colored veins on Venom's shoulder those
could be connected to some white design
on his chest
some sources are suggesting that it
could be a large V I guess it's a little
silly but don't knock it I got a big V
tattooed on my chest for voss wait no no
no not not perversion
damn people are gonna think that but
what connection do you want spider-man
to have in this story is it possible to
have venom without spider-man or can the
anti-hero exist on his own seriously
movie execs at Sony are dying to know
comment down below with your thoughts or
tweet me directly at Yale us and follow
new rockstars on Twitter for updates on
your videos like and share this video
and subscribe to new rock stars for all
of our deep dives into venom and
spider-man and everything Marvel related
seriously we're doing a ton of stuff on
a pin if you were this week so be sure
to check out all of those great deep
dives thanks for watching guys bye